Deutschlands berühmteste
YouTube-Eltern, Bibi und Julian,
haben vor Kurzem announced,
dass sie ihr Kind
nicht mehr vor
der Öffentlichkeit verstecken wollen,
sondern zeigen möchten.
Jetzt haben nicht
alle Eltern Mio.Abonnenten,
aber wir nutzen alle Social Media.
Wahrscheinlich
fragen sich viele Eltern,
wie sie am besten
mit Sharenting umgehen sollen,
eine Wort-Kombi
aus sharing und parenting,
die sogar Einzug
in die Medienforschung genommen hat.
Persönliche Meinungen
gibt es viele zu dem Thema,
aber ich fragte mich:
Gibt es so etwas wie
Experten-Meinungen oder Forschungen?
Ich habe tatsächlich
ganz interessante Dinge gefunden,
die ich mit euch teilen möchte
und die vielleicht dabei helfen,
die Debatte sachlicher
und konstruktiver zu führen.
* Titelmelodie *
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)
Es gibt auf jeden Fall Vorteile
von Social Media für Eltern.
Abgesehen davon,
dass man schöne Momente
mit anderen Menschen teilen kann,
und das eigene Kind ist natürlich für
viele Eltern das Schönste im Leben,
nutzen viele Eltern
Social Media auch,
um Support und Tipps zu bekommen.
Laut einer amerikanischen Umfrage des
Pew Research Center sagten das 2015
bereits 75-80% der befragten Eltern.
Und von unserer MaiLab-Grafikerin
Melanie weiß ich z.B. auch,
dass gerade
der Anfang des Elterndaseins
viele Unsicherheiten und Ängste
mit sich bringt
und man froh ist zu sehen,
dass es anderen auch so geht,
dass man eine Möglichkeit hat,
sich auszutauschen.
Doch die Nachteile
liegen auf der Hand:
Eingriff in die Privatsphäre
der Kinder ohne deren Zustimmung.
Und, ne, Internet,
alles was irgendwann gepostet wird,
kann dich
bis ins Erwachsenenalter verfolgen.
Dann fragt man sich auch:
Hat das psychologische Auswirkungen
auf Kinder,
gerade wenn man als Kind
von YouTubern aufwächst,
die Mio.Abonnenten haben
oder als Kind von Reality-Stars
wie den Kardashians?
Ich find's
nicht sinnvoll zu fragen,
soll ich oder soll ich nicht,
denn dafür
ist das Internet und Social Media
ein zu großer Teil unseres Lebens,
ich finde die viel
konstruktivere Frage ist:
Wie kann ich mit den Daten und
Informationen meiner Kinder im Netz
verantwortungsvoll umgehen?
Das haben sich
auch diese Kinderärzte gefragt
und folgende Empfehlungen abgegeben.
...der Apps und Plattformen,
die ihr benutzt.
Nicht nur darauf achten,
ob ein Post öffentlich,
privat oder nur für Freunde ist,
sondern:
Kostenlose Apps und Plattformen
finanzieren sich über Werbeeinnahmen.
Das bedeutet,
dass persönliche Infos an
Werbetreibende weitergegeben werden.
So kriegt man als weiblicher Nutzer
Werbung für Lippenstift angezeigt,
als männlicher Nutzer
für Holzfäller-Zubehör.
Außerdem sind Social-
Media-Plattformen oft leicht hackbar.
Man findet immer wieder Wege,
private Post von Plattformen wie
Instagram oder Facebook als Fremder
doch einzusehen und runterzuladen.
Und selbst augenscheinlich
unschuldige Kinder- und Jugendfotos,
die Kinder
müssen nicht mal halbnackt sein,
können missbraucht und in Datenbanken
pädophiler Kreise gelangen.
Social-Media-Plattformen
sind für solche
Fotos und Videos die Nr.1-Quelle.
Wenn ihr euch einen Google-Alert
oder sowas einrichtet,
bekommt ihr immer
'ne Benachrichtigung,
wenn z.B. online jemand
den Namen eures Kindes erwähnt.
So habt ihr ein Auge drauf,
wenn sich vielleicht Informationen
weiter verbreiten,
als ihr das möchtet.
Macht es, wenn dann, anonym.
Der Klassiker
sind gesundheitliche Probleme.
Also etwas ist seltsam,
man macht sich Sorgen,
man kriegt nicht
sofort einen Arzttermin,
dann erkundigt
man sich erst mal online.
Ich kann generell davon abraten, sich
online medizinisch beraten zu lassen.
Ihr wisst,
im Netz steht so viel Quatsch,
also lasst euch
bitte professionell beraten.
Aber v.a. sind
gesundheitliche Infos hochsensibel
und nicht
für die Öffentlichkeit gedacht.
Nicht umsonst unterliegen Ärzte
einer Schweigepflicht.
Das gilt nicht nur
für körperliche Beschwerden,
sondern auch für psychische, z.B.
sowas wie Verhaltensauffälligkeiten.
Ist ja klar, der Name
ist ein wichtiger Schlüssel,
um Infos
über einen Menschen zu bekommen.
Vor allem die Sache
mit dem Aufenthaltsort ist etwas,
dass wir alle auf dem Schirm haben
sollten, egal, ob Eltern oder nicht.
Gerade mit Storys, die viele
mehr oder weniger live posten,
mit verlinktem Ort,
denkt immer darüber nach,
ob das vielleicht
ein Sicherheitsrisiko sein könnte
oder ob ihr die Story nicht
erst mal speichert und dann postet,
wenn ihr von dem Ort weg seid.
Selbst wenn ihr es
nicht aktiv verlinkt,
immer auf dem Schirm haben,
dass Fotos und Videos
auch Metadaten enthalten,
die z.B. den Ort preisgeben können,
wo das Foto gemacht wurde.
Punkt 5, ist klar, würde ich sagen:
Gebt ihnen die Möglichkeit,
Veto einzulegen.
Die aktuelle Debatte dreht sich
in 1.Linie um Babys und Kinder,
die so jung sind, dass sie
noch nicht mitreden können.
Da sind
die nächsten 2 Punkte wichtig:
Wie vorhin schon gesagt, auch
unschuldige Fotos werden missbraucht.
Aber natürlich, wenn das Kind auf
der Toilette ist, im Bad, am Strand,
ist das Risiko für einen Missbrauch
natürlich deutlich höher.
Die Kampagne "Dein Kind auch nicht"
weist darauf hin, dass man nichts
von seinem Kind posten sollte,
was man auch nicht
von sich selbst posten würde,
egal, wie süß oder lustig man
das in dem Moment findet.
Das gilt auch für die Eltern,
die das Gesicht ihrer Kinder
unkenntlich machen,
die zwar Sachen posten, aber es
dann blurren oder Emojis draufpacken.
Kann man natürlich machen,
wenn man das so möchte,
aber trotz allem
ist es damit nicht getan.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Dinge,
an die man denken muss.
Passend dazu diese aktuelle Studie,
bei der Jugendliche zwischen 12-14
befragt wurden,
welches Posting-Verhalten sie gerne
von ihren Eltern gesehen hätten.
Die Befragten fanden Sharenting
prinzipiell in Ordnung.
Also alleine die Tatsache,
dass sie damals nicht gefragt wurden
oder nicht mitreden konnten,
war nicht das Problem,
sondern erst, wenn bestimmte Grenzen
überschritten wurden.
Also wenn Bilder oder Posts
peinlich oder unangenehm waren,
negative Kommentare mit sich zogen,
die man dann auch
irgendwann zu lesen bekommt.
Auch Oversharenting
war ihnen unangenehm.
Wenn man also
zu viele Informationen preisgibt,
wenn der ganze Alltag
nach außen getragen wird.
Man könnte sagen:
Die Dosis macht das Gift.
Dass es dann sogar noch Eltern gibt,
die ihre Kinder
zu Influencern machen,
mit ihren Kindern ganze
Kanäle oder Profile betreiben,
mit Kindern, die so jung sind, die
das nicht umfassend begreifen können,
dass das höchst problematisch ist,
darüber müssen wir nicht reden.
Ich würde noch 2 Punkte hinzufügen:
Wenn ich mich auf meinem YouTube-
Kanal wie der letzte Depp verhalte,
kann das negative Auswirkungen
auf alle Menschen haben,
die mit mir privat verbandelt sind.
Dazu zählen auch meine Kinder.
Wobei "Depp" natürlich
im Auge des Betrachters steht.
Die Schwester
von Greta Thunberg z.B.,
die selbst nicht
in der Öffentlichkeit ist,
wird gemobbt von Leuten,
die Gretas Aktivismus kacke finden.
Gerade Mobbing hat durch das Internet
noch mal
andere Dimensionen angenommen.
Das ist noch mal
ein anderes grundsätzliches Problem,
was man unabhängig davon
angehen müsste.
Nenne ich das mal.
Wir Menschen sind soziale Wesen.
Unsere sozialen Interaktionen
werden erweitert
um soziale Interaktionen im Netz.
Und die können echt viel sein.
Ich persönlich bin echt froh,
dass ich schon 28 war,
als ich mit YouTube angefangen hab.
Also als erwachsene Frau
kann ich mit der Flut an Kommentaren
und der vielen Aufmerksamkeit
und der Gefahr,
dass man seinen Selbstwert an sowas
wie Likes oder Views knüpfen könnte,
da kann ich ganz entspannt umgehen.
Wenn ihr mir auf Social Media folgt,
kann ich mal kurz pluggen,
aber wisst ihr leider auch,
dass ich Phasen habe,
wo ich wochen- oder
monatelang nichts poste,
weil ich
gerade nicht so viel Bock hab
und mir da auch
keinen Druck mache oder so.
Aber mit 18 wäre ich mit dem ganzen
Trubel nicht so gut klargekommen.
Ich finde, dass nicht nur
negative Aufmerksamkeit belastet,
Beleidigungen oder
sonstige negativen Kommentare,
sondern zu viel Aufmerksamkeit
an sich ist nicht ohne.
Man kann darüber nachdenken,
bevor man
zu viel von seinen Kindern postet.
Selbst wenn sie es
später nicht peinlich finden sollten,
setzt man sie trotzdem
dieser öffentlichen Beurteilung
und Aufmerksamkeit aus,
die Social Media mit sich bringt.
Man hört immer wieder,
dass Social Media
durch den ständigen Vergleich und die
Oberflächlichkeit unglücklich macht.
Ich finde die Langzeitstudie
ganz interessant.
Die begleitete Jugendliche
in England, von 13-16.
Die Ergebnisse zeigen zunächst,
dass ein häufiger Gebrauch
von Social Media
für Mädchen, aber nicht für Jungs
einhergeht mit einer Verminderung
des Wohlbefindens
und der Lebenszufriedenheit.
Hier muss man genau hinschauen:
Die Probleme hingen spezifisch
zusammen mit Mobbing, Cyber-Mobbing,
und mit positiven Dingen, die wegen
Social Media auf der Strecke bleiben,
z.B. Schlaf oder Sport.
Wenn man den Einfluss
dieser Dinge statistisch rausrechnet,
sieht man, sowohl für die Jungs
als auch für die Mädchen,
keinen Zusammenhang
zwischen Social Media
und einer Verminderung der
Zufriedenheit und des Wohlbefindens.
Es kommt in dieser Studie
weniger darauf an,
ob man sozialen Medien
an sich ausgesetzt ist,
sondern ob man dort Mobbing erfährt
oder ob das auf Kosten
von Schlaf oder Sport geht.
Die Möglichkeiten im Netz
und unser Medienkonsum,
das alles ändert
sich so schnell derzeit,
dass Forschung und Wissenschaft
kaum hinterherkommen.
So etwas wie Langzeitstudien
sind total schwierig.
Es gibt deswegen tatsächlich
auch wenige handfeste Daten.
Trotzdem, denke ich, kann man
die Ergebnisse dieser Studie
auf viele andere Bereiche übertragen.
Es geht nicht in 1.Linie darum,
ob wir Social Media
nutzen und wie viel,
sondern es ist viel wichtiger,
wie wir es nutzen.
Dass wir, genau wie im analogen
Leben, verantwortungsvoll handeln.
Ich finde es nicht
sinnvoll zu sagen,
dass man pauschal Kinder
nicht im Internet zeigen sollte,
nur weil sie nicht mitreden können.
Denn ich werde jetzt bald Mutter,
werde bald viele Entscheidungen
für mein Kind treffen müssen,
wo es nicht mitreden kann.
Das fängt damit an,
welche Klamotten ich ihm anziehe
und geht bis hin zu wichtigen
medizinischen Entscheidungen,
die ich treffen werde.
Und welche Fotos
ich wie und mit wem teile,
ist noch eine weitere Entscheidung,
die alle Eltern
für sich und ihre Kinder
verantwortungsvoll treffen müssen.
Wie ist das bei euch?
Haben eure Eltern
schon peinliche Kinderfotos
eingescannt und im Netz hochgeladen?
Ihr fandet es nicht so cool?
Wer hat schon Kinder?
Wie geht ihr damit um?
Habt ihr euch darüber
schon Gedanken gemacht?
Ich freue mich dieses Mal
total auf eure Kommentare.
Ich freue mich immer,
aber dieses Mal besonders.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin: bleibt sicher.